[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meiner trocknet
heute gibt's noch ein paar kauft ihre
rezepte von mir und von sabine tango wir
sehen heute weil der kabine zu hause
dass ich meine freundin und wir möchten
heute drei rezepte machen und zwar
einwohner rezept und zwei ganz einfach
cocktailrezepte genau alles nicht
alkoholische aber ihr könnt natürlich
eben jeden cocktail auch alkohol mit
einmischen und wir zeigen euch einfach
mal was 14 tagen da haben und zwar habe
mir hier ein pole gefäß und da werden
wir das gleich rein machen und haben
jetzt gedacht dass wir es aus
traubensaft nehmen soll es besitzt und
dann geht man da etwas mineralwasser
dazu mit kohlensäure
da könnte aber auch gerne berate nehmen
allerdings wird es dann eben süßer wir
geben oder orangensaft rein und trainer
den sirup
ich hoffe ich spreche jetzt richtig aus
dass ich in alkoholfreien sirup und der
wirt aus granatäpfeln gewonnen und muss
man noch aufpassen welche marke ihr
nimmt und wenn immer noch ein bisschen
cranberries ihr und für die säure dann
haben wir hier noch ein paar limetten
ein granatapfel und mit zitrone hier
noch eine orange und eine stern frucht
so zu deko zwecken und ein paar
eiswürfel da kommen aber gleich noch
dazu und jetzt würde ich sage starten
wir und zwar hab mich schon mal
eiswürfel vorbereitet und zwar gibt es
da so eiswürfel typen und wir haben
jetzt hier einmal wasser ein
also ganz normaler einkünfte sind und
hier haben wir jeweils saft eingeführt
ich habe jetzt hier zum beispiel
kirschsaft drin bist nicht immer denkt
jetzt für unsere bohne und zwar geht es
einfach so dass ihr die tüte nehmen und
auftritt und dann könnte entweder saft
oder eben wasser nehmen und bis dahin
für und dann fand ich das eben da unten
in den tüten und so kann man das
einfrieren und später dann einfach
ausdrücken ihr könnte es aber natürlich
auch einen ganz normalen eiswürfel
behälter machen also durch am so ganz
praktisch mal was so wenig platz
verbracht
im schrank hat und jetzt haben wir
unsere schale und möchten da auch noch
ein paar kanada pixel mit rein gegeben
und zwar gibt es einen ganz einfachen
trick wie ihr die granata fred kern dann
könnten strikt nein konstante idee und
zwar ich das ja immer so eine ziemliche
sauerei wenn man das macht und jetzt
zeitlich nicht einmal wie das ganz
einfach geht und zwar nehmt euch dann
einfach ein messer und riss die haut
oben ein aber geradezu ansetzen wenn er
nämlich durchschneidet dann schneidet
ihr hier auch die kerner durch und dann
spritzt das ja auch und dann könne man
das einmal halbieren
das ist knifflig
und dann habt ihr das schön getrennt
unternehmen wir euch eine kleine schale
und nehmt euch so eine suppenkelle und
klopft damit im rücken einfach drauf und
dann falle die von ganz alleine mehr
rein und so habt ihr das wirklich ohne
vorbei
dann haben wir das schon in desperate
escape ein kopf mit aufgeschnittener tag
ein paar meter fugen
ich habe jetzt vier statt und ich dann
haben wir die als nummer drei nicht und
habe noch schönen und dann gebe ich noch
etwa 50 milliliter von diesem trainer
den ist die hochrhein und dagegen nur
etwa 40 milliliter von diesen krempeln
ihr auch mit rein ist natürlich alles
nicht vorschnell wer als ihr könnt ja
auch was anderes nehmen dann irgendwie
noch etwa 300 liter orangensaft teilen
und noch einen halben liter wasser also
die sich jetzt sprudelndes mineralwasser
und gegen die limonade entschieden weil
es dann eben einfach zu chance mehr noch
der traumhaft mit der zunge
trifft ein ganzer liter und dann könnte
da eben für die frische noch ein paar
limetten scheiben und zitronenscheiben
und orangenscheiben dazugeben und beide
elemente mache ich es immer so dass ich
sie einmal durch drückt dann kommt es
auch drauf
[Musik]
wo sind die ohren
münchen münchen und während ich meine da
könnte ja obst und antrieben sowie es ja
gehabt hoffe ich das ist klar
[Musik]
auf euch endlich hab dachte wieso
zusammen gar nicht geschmeckt brot
sollten wir alle nachmachen doch schnitt
echt lecker und ein zipfel kann man ja
auch mehr raum geben so mehr möglich
foto welches mit anderen autobauern
das kann auch noch nico auf jeden fall
gezeigt was sich lohnt oder wenn ich
sage packen wir die bühne weg und zeigen
gleich den cocktail und in die bowle
können dann natürlich auch etwas sekt
geben aber ich würde euch da empfehlen
er seinen trockenen sec zu nehmen dass
es eben nicht so süß wird ich denke dass
das bestimmt auch gut meinte wenn man
eine party feiert mit bestimmten und
jetzt machen wir diesen einen cocktail
und weichen cocktail da wirklich toll
aus sie dem glas dass ich auch ein
alkoholfreier kann man aber natürlich
auch an gefährlich machen und zwar
brauchen wir dafür etwas ananassaft und
maracujasaft wir nehmen auch noch etwas
orangensaft und für die farbe dann noch
etwas sauerkirschen und da haben wir
jetzt vorbereitet ananas und maracuja
mehr als 1
und das ganze wasser eiswürfeln würde
ich noch unsere kirche eiswürfel und es
geht jetzt ganz schnell jetzt gleich
zwei minuten fertig ist dann machen wir
das erst ein bisschen anderen astra
sondern ein bisschen von julia vorher
immer schön sutil und dem auch gleich
die eiswürfel mit dazu und da könnte
auch ganz gut etwas sektenfragen geben
daneben heute auch mal aber den sieg
würde ich dann hier schon rein ja auf
jeden fall also jetzt gern grund geld
noch dazu und jetzt nehme mandaten
kirschsaft und lassen den ganz leicht
über so ein eiswürfel laufen dann müsste
es nämlich passieren dass unten das geld
bleibt oben rot als auch der seite fehlt
noch ein bisschen
naja egal spiel trotzdem goutieren
damit seien alle leichter effekt
strohhalm schmeckt auch gut und schmeckt
doch gleich noch verbreitern wir was hat
man was haben wollen mir vor aufspielen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und das passiert schon beim nicht
alkoholische cocktails
oh ja jetzt kommen wir ganz frische
guckte er schmeckt richtig lecker mit
ginger ale und minze denn waren wir zu
euch kommen jetzt endlich wieder
aufgestellt ich mache ich mache mich
gleich gemacht nicht mehr und so
wirkliche macht da schon entscheidungen
[Gelächter]
muss die kamera einstimmen mit entnommen
und für dieses getränk brauchen wir nur
drei zutaten einmal ginger ale frischer
pfefferminze und ein paar entwürfe dann
hat es mir besser macht geht es nämlich
viel besser und dann könnt ihr hier
einfach etwas älteren können wir auch
war steuerung benutzer so eine studie
und wenn ihr dann die mindest verschafft
die hand nehmen und einmal so drauf
klatscht dann entfaltet sich die
ätherische öle und dann kommt schon das
aroma aus wettbewerbs- und dann kommt da
das ginger ale drauf
also mit dem messer glaubt ist wirklich
viel besser einschätzen
es ist richtig schön braucht und fertig
euro frisches gedrängt probiert um
sollten sich heute sehen muss noch
ziehen ja sein dass ein bisschen noch
bisschen genau das ist übrigens die
kabinette ihr euch immer auf die e mails
antwortet wenn er über meinen shops edis
fahrradshop de eine kontaktanfrage
baltisches wie sabina de beantwortet
hast bin ich meine babys haben ja nicht
antworten zu hindern
ach ja mit zwei kindern diesmal wohl
bemerken york und haushalt und arbeit
und man ahnt schon dass ich das größte
argument ist auch da man ja auch weniger
freuen will genau
ja auf jeden fall hoffen wir dass euch
die drei rezepte gefallen und schmecken
zu sagen
alle drei getränke alles super party
rezepten ja genau und auch dieses ginger
ale können dann natürlich wieder auf
treppen mit etwas angehoben
wenn ihr uns wollt mir wird es auch im
land mussten aber kati oder sowie die
auf whistler wodka gemacht das ist nicht
so schnell kinder auf jeden fall
wünschen wir euch viel spaß danach
machen wir nichts machen wollte und
lacht uns gerne einen kommentar das
ambiente stimmt wieder mal in dem video
mit dabei zu sein ja dann schreib mir
komm mal genauer und die rezepte gibt's
zum nachlesen auf www.starbett.de
[Gelächter]
also gleich kannst du dich ja und ich
mache es mir wollte wieder vor
[Gelächter]
heute kann man war so weit weg ist aber
da kann ich da klingeln an sich vorbei
das gemacht was ich bin heute bei wenn
sie eigentlich muss ich dann gut daran
jetzt hallo herzlich willkommen in
meiner tragen weltweit möchte ich noch
mal
[Gelächter]
hast du etwa halb so stark nach wald
arena von unnötiger begrüßen
[Gelächter]
rang vor
[Musik]
b
in gefahr
[Musik]
das geht nicht
auch das nicht
sie kennt
[Musik]